>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN DECIDING NOT
TO EXTEND THE AUGUST 31st
DEADLINE FROM WITHDRAWING FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
THE PRESIDENT SITING A MAJOR
SECURITY RISK THAT GROWS BIGGER
EVERY SINGLE DAY U.S. TROOPS
REMAIN ON THE GROUND THERE.
HE SAYS THAT HE ASKED FOR A
CONTINGENCY PLANS IN CASE FORCES
NEED TO REMAIN IN THE COUNTRY
LONGER.
EVACUATIONS HAVE BEEN RAPIDLY
INCREASING BUT MANY AMERICANS
AND AFGHAN ALLIES ARE STILL
DESPERATELY TRYING TO GET OUT.
JOINING ME NOW THE FORMER
DEFENSE SECRETARY WILLIAM COHEN.
SECRETARY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US.
LET'S START BY TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT HOLDIING STEADY ON THT
DEADLINE OF WITHDRAWAL A COUPLE
DAYS, AUGUST 31st, ONE WEEK
LEFT.
IS IT THE RIGHT CALL?
>> DON, TIME WILL TELL ON THIS
FOR SURE, BUT I HAVE TO SAY I
HAVE MIXED EMOTIONS TODAY.
I'M PROFOUNDLY GRATEFUL TO OUR
MILITARY AND I WANT EVERYBODY
WATCHING HERE OR ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD TO LOOK AT THAT MILITARY
TO SEE WHAT WE'RE CAPABLE OF, TO
SEE THE KIND OF CAPABILITY, THE
INDIVIDUAL SOLDIERS, MARINES AND
OTHERS HAVE GOING FROM
HUMANITARIANS TO PEACE KEEPERS
TO WAROARRIORS AND DIPLOMATS
WRAPPED IN ONE.
WE HAVE TO BE ENORMOUSLY
GRATEFUL TO THE JOB THEY'RE
DOING WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT
PERSONNEL WHO ARE PROCESSING
THESE VISAS AT AN INCREDIBLE
SPEED UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND AT RISK TO THEIR LIVES, AS
WELL.
I AM DEPRESSED TO SEE THAT THERE
ARE GOING TO BE MANY PEOPLE THAT
WON'T GET TO THE AIRPORT, THAT
THE TALIBAN HAS SAID SHUTTING
DOWN THE AVENUES OR THE ACCESS
TO THE AIRPORT, THAT MEANS FEWER
PEOPLE WILL BE GETTING ON THOSE
PLANES.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT NOT EVERYBODY
THAT SUPPORTED US WILL GET OUT
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION FOR THEM TO GET OUT
AND I GO BACK AND LOOK FOR
PARALLELS IN TIME AND I WAS
THINKING OF BACK IN 1959, THE
FRENCH FINALLY RECOGNIZED
ALGERIA INDEPENDENCE AFTER
HAVING AS MANY AS 500,000 TROOPS
IN THIS COUNTRY AT SOMETIME AND
TIME TO RECOGNIZE THE
INDEPENDENCE OF ALGERIA AND MANY
ADVISORS SAID BUT WE'VE SHED SO
MUCH BLOOD AND NAGAL SAID BLOOD
TRIES QUICKLY.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
CONTEND WITH AND COMPREHEND.
WILL THE BLOOD OF THOSE WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED, ALL OF THE VETERANS
WHO HAVE BEEN IN AFGHANISTAN WHO
HAVE LOST FRIENDS AND LOST LIMBS
AND ALL THAT THEY'VE GIVEN, WILL
THEY FORGET THIS?
WILL THERE BE A MORAL AMNESIA?
I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK ANYBODY WHO HAS BEEN
THERE WILL NOT FORGET, BUT YOU
GET TO BE PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE TO
DECIDE.
I'VE BEEN ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS
ISSUE HAVING SERVED IN CONGRESS
AND SAYING HERE IS MY
RECOMMENDATION, MR. PRESIDENT
AND THEN BEEN IN THE CABINET AND
SAYS THE PRESIDENT HAS TO
DECIDE, CONGRESS DOESN'T REALLY
MAKE THE DECISION THE PRESIDENT
MAKES.
HE'S MADE IT AND WE'LL HAVE TO
SEE HOW IT UNFOLDS.
>> LET ME SAY THIS.
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THERE IS NO
DENYING THAT GETTING MORE THAN
70,000 PEOPLE EVACUATED IN TEN
DAYS, THAT IS REMARKABLE.
IT WAS A ROUGH BEGINNING, NO
DOUBT.
YOU SAW THE PICTURES.
JUST -- WHAT IS YOUR VIEW OF A
SUCCESSFUL THRESHOLD FOR THESE
EVACUATIONS AND PART TWO OF THAT
QUESTION, IS IT REALLY REALISTIC
TO THINK THAT AMERICA CAN OR
SHOULD -- MAYBE THEY SHOULD BE
BUT CAN GET EVERY SINGLE PERSON
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN WHO WANTS TO
LEAVE, IS THAT REALISTIC?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I DON'T THINK IT'S POSSIBLE.
ALTHOUGH WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST
TEN DAYS SOMETHING THAT WAS SEEN
AS BEING DISASTROUS GO TO
SOMETHING REMARKABLE.
SO ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE AND
NOTHING IS INEVITABLE UNTIL IT
HAPPENS.
BUT NONETHELESS, I THINK TRYING
TO GET EVERYONE, EVERY AMERICAN
TO BE SURE BUT EVERYONE WHOSE
SUPPORTED US AND WORKED WITH US,
IDENTIFY THEM AND HAVE THEM GET
THROUGH THE CHECK POINT TO GET
ON THE PLANES AND GET OUT WILL
BE VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE BUT
WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE ON
THAT.
>> WAS THAT REALISTIC EVEN TO
GET EVERYONE OUT?
>> I DON'T THINK IT REALISTIC.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN TRIED TO LAY THE
FOUNDATION AND SAY WE'LL DO OUR
BEST.
FIRST COME THE AMERICANS AND
THEN COME THOSE IN LINE WITH THE
PROPER IDENTIFICATION VISA AND
HELP AND I THINK THAT'S ALL
THAT'S GOING TO BE ACCOMPLISHED
AND SOME WILL BE LEFT BEHIND AND
THE QUESTION IS WILL THAT BLOOD
DRY QUICKLY?
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WILL LOSE
THEIR LIVES.
NOW, WE HAVE SOME LEVERAGE OVER
THE TALIBAN.
WE HAVE ECONOMIC LEVERAGE AND BY
THE WAY, WITH THE CIA DIRECTOR
HAVING GONE OVER THERE, IT WILL
BE INTERESTING TO FIND WHAT THE
NATURE OF HIS CONVERSATIONS
WERE --
>> LET ME PLAY THIS BECAUSE
YOU'RE RESPONDING TO IT.
WHAT THE SECRETARY IS TALKING
ABOUT WILLIAM BURNS MET WITH THE
TALIBAN IN KABUL ON MONDAY.
THE TALIBAN SET A RED LINE ON
DELAYING THE WITHDRAWAL AND THIS
IS WHAT THE PENTAGON
SPOKESPERSON JOHN KIRBY WAS
ASKED TODAY AND WE'LL GET THE
SECRETARY'S RESPONSE.
>> THE PUBLIC STATEMENTS BY THE
TALIBAN THE SAME AS THE PRIVATE
STATEMENTS BEING MADE TO U.S.
OFFICIALS ABOUT THE DEADLINE AND
WHEN U.S. SHOULD LEAVE?
>> WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
THE TALIBAN HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR
ABOUT WHAT THEIR EXPECTATIONS
ARE, AS WELL.
>> WHAT THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
STATEMENTS ARE THE SAME?
>> WITHOUT GETTING INTO DETAILS,
I'M NOT SEEING MUCH DISSONANCE.
>> YOU WERE SPEAKING ABOUT THAT
ISSUE.
TALIBAN CALLING THE SHOTS HERE,
PLEASE GO ON, SORRY FOR
INTERRUPTING BUT I WANTED TO
PLAY THAT FOR YOU.
>> THEY ARE CALLING THE SHOTS
BUT WE HAVE SOME LEVERAGE WITH
THEM.
AFTER WE LEAVE WE'LL CERTAINLY
HAVE AN INTELLIGENCE CAPABILITY,
NOT AS GREAT AS IT HAS BEEN BUT
NONETHELESS, I WON'T PREDICT
THIS BUT SPECULATE ABOUT IT.
THE TALIBAN MAY BE CALLING UPON
OUR INTELLIGENCE SERVICES TO
HELP SAVE THEM FROM ISIS K AND
FROM ALIBI DA.
THEY WILL BE IN TROUBLE
ECONOMICALLY AND I THINK THEY
WILL BE ASSAULTED FROM THE
EXTREMIST GROUPS MORE EXTREME
THAN THEM.
THEY WILL HAVE TO FIGHT THAT
WAR, AS WELL.
I THINK THE CIA DIRECTOR WAS
PROBABLY SENDING A MESSAGE ABOUT
WHAT OUR CAPABILITIES ARE, WHAT
OUR EXPECTATIONS ARE AND WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IN THE EVENT THAT
THEY DON'T ABIDE BY THE
AGREEMENT TO DATE AND DON'T GIVE
US A LITTLE LEEWAY AFTER AUGUST
31st.
I DON'T KNOW THAT BUT I'M
DELIGHTED THAT THE DIRECTOR
BURNS WENT THERE, OPENED THE
LINE OF COMMUNICATION AND BETTER
THAT COMES FROM THE CIA THAN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
THAT WOULD GIVE THEM TOO MUCH
LEGITIMACY AND WE'RE NOT READY,
NOT PREPARED TO DO THAT AT THIS
POINT, IF EVER.
A LOT WILL DEPEND UPON HOW THEY
BEHIAVE IN THE NEXT WEEK, MONTH
AND YEAR BEFORE WE HAVE A FORMAL
RECOGNITION, IF ANY.
>> SECRETARY, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HELPED RELEASE
THE TALIBAN LEADER FROM PRISON.
TRUMP SPOKE WITH HIM ON THE
PHONE IN MARCH OF 2020 AFTER
MAKING A DEAL WITH THE TALIBAN.
DID ALL THIS GIVE THE TALIBAN
MORE CLOUT THAN WE MARGE BARGAI
FOR?
>> I THINK IT ABSOLUTELY DID.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT SAID AND
BOASTED ON TELEVISION AT A
RALLY, I BOXED IN THE MILITARY.
I BOXED IN BIDEN.
I DID THAT DELIBERATELY SO HE
WOULD HAVE LITTLE MOVE OR THEY
WOULD HAVE LITTLE ROOM FOR
MANEUVER AND SO PRESIDENT BIDEN
COMES IN.
HE HAS LITTLE ROOM FOR MANEUVER
BUT EXTENDED IT SOMEWHAT.
PEOPLE CAN ARGUE WHETHER HE
SHOULD HAVE EXTENDED A LOT
FURTHER AT THAT POINT BUT
NONETHELESS, I THINK HE'S PRETTY
MUCH BOXED IN AS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT PUT HIM IN THAT BOX TO
BEGIN WITH.
I WANT TO COME BACK TO THIS.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT, SAY,
POLITICAL DECISION ON THE PART
OF PRESIDENT OBAMA BIDEN IN THE
SENSE OF IT BEING PARTISAN OR
POLITICAL IN MOTIVATION.
THIS IS PHILOSOPHICAL FOR HIM.
HE'S ABSOLUTELY OPPOSED TO OUR
CONTINUED PRESENCE IN
AFGHANISTAN AND WAS OPPOSED, I
THINK, PRETTY CLOSE TO THE
BEGINNING ONCE HE SAW THAT WE
EXPANDED THE MISSION TO NATION
BUILDING.
I'VE SAID THIS ON THIS NETWORK.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO ENGAGE IN
NATION BUILDING AND A FOREIGN
COUNTRY, YOU BETTER BE PREPARED
TO BE THERE NOT 20 YEARS BUT 40
AND 50 AND MAYBE EVEN 100 YEARS
TO TRY TO CHANGE THE CULTURE.
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE HERE IN THIS COUNTRY AND
THE NOTION THAT A FOREIGN
OCCUPATION FORCE COULD COME IN
AND TRY AND CHANGE OUR CULTURE
IN A 20-YEAR PERIOD IS PRETTY
RIDICULOUS.
WE HAVE TO GET A LITTLE MORE
CONSCIOUS OF CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY, A LITTLE MORE
CULTURAL INTELLIGENCE AS OUR
GENERALS HAVE SAID IN THE PAST.
WE'RE NOT AWARE OF THE TRIABLE
NATURE OF AFGHANISTAN.
WE WEREN'T AWARE OF IT.
WE SHOULDN'T TAKE IT INTO
CONSIDERATION.
WE THOUGHT WE COULD ACTUALLY IN
A 20-YEAR PERIOD BUILD SOMETHING
RESEMBLING A WESTERN SITYLE
DEMOCRACY.
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO CONCEDE.
I HOPE WE'VE LEARNED THIS LESSON
AGAIN WE HAVE TO HAVE A REAL
FOCUSED MISSION AND NOT EXPAND
THAT MISSION BEYOND OUR
CAPABILITIES AND IF WE'RE GOING
TO DO THAT, DO IT FROM THE
OUTSET SAYING WE'LL BE THERE A
LONG TIME AND WE'LL SPEND MORE
AND MORE MONEY AND RISK MORE AND
MORE LIVES.
BUT I DON'T THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT THAT.
I THINK IT'S AGAIN A
PHILOSOPHICAL DECISION MORE THAN
A POLITICAL OR PARTISAN ONE AND
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW IT UNFOLDS
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE MADE THE DECISION.
WE'LL HAVE TO LIVE WITH IT AS
BEST WE CAN.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE WILL
SUFFER AS A RESULT.
I THINK THE AFGHAN PEOPLE WILL
SUFFER.
I THINK THE WOMEN CERTAINLY ARE
GO
GOING TO SUFFER, WE'LL HAVE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE LEVERAGE TO
PERSUADE THEM AND MAYBE THEY
LEARNED TO SEE THEIR SOCIETY
CHANGED AT LEAST IN THE URBAN
AREAS AND WHERE THE SOCIETY NOW
HAVING ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY.
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY KNOWS BUT
WE'RE IN A POSITION LIKE A
PYTHON SQUEEZED THEM
ECONOMICALLY AND DIPLOMATICALLY
AND ULTIMATELY FROM AN
INTELLIGENCE POINT OF VIEW
CERTAINLY NOT BRINGING ANY
ASSETS TO BEAR THAT MIGHT HELP
THEM IN THE FUTURE THAT THEY MAY
NEED.
ONE FINAL THING, WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT COVID.
WE TALKED ABOUT COVID HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT COVID IN
AFGHANISTAN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY COMING IN,
I HOPE THEY'RE ALL BEING CHECKED
FOR COVID IN OUR COUNTRY BUT IF
COVID IS SPREADING IN
AFGHANISTAN, THEY WON'T BE ABLE
TO CARRY ON AS A SOCIETY IF THEY
ARE DYING.
WE HAVE SOME LEVERAGE TO BE
SURE, SOME HELP TO BE SURE
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED IN ORDER
TO SURVIVE AS A FUNCTIONING
GOVERNMENT.
AND WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE
HOW THAT PLAYS OUT.
>> WE'RE SMARTER FOR HAVING